che quello che se di colore su sanità e
oggi li faremo la tre colori dipendere
il galles
però questa volta chi segnerà i colori
non ci si sta mangiando le forchette
challenge noi avremo disegni a testa
ogni volta e berlino sceglierà tre
colori di pennarelli addirittura li
dovremo correre sul disegno solo con
quei tre colori poi vi faremo vedere il
disegno e potrete votare nei sondaggi
qua quale disegno vincesse il mio o
quello di vitale in battere come è stato
colorato o se è tutta colpa di berlino
tutti i colori fini sono super curioso
di vedere come uscirà top challenge
guardate il video fino alla fine per
votare tutti i disegni qua e vi ricordo
anche che uscita per mentre la sigla
ufficiale della serie anita stories la
serie animata che uscirà qua sul mio
canale se non l'avete vista
andate a vederla alla fine di questo
video di un bel mi piace vedere oltre
all'incidente di hip hop carne mettetevi
comodi preso super ok allora sveliamo
innanzitutto il nostro primo disegno che
dovevamo colorare 32
abbiamo paura non è stato super creato
di vedere come la coloreremo e ve la
facciamo vedere anche originale perché
questa ce l'ho ce l'ho in due versioni
rosa e con le scarpine colorate per con
la chioma dorata e anche la codeina
dorata quindi vediamo chi si avvicinerà
di più all'originale con i tre colori
che si saluteranno preso era
completamente diversa non lo sto nasone
appoggiato insomma perché ho bisogno di
prendere i dettagli controllati non
cederemo a rivederle e ora facciamo
scegliere tre colori aver liberi tutti
allora iniziamo il primo valore lasciami
e per vitale
vediamo un po con le serie quale sceglie
un attimo vediamo il secondo colore per
vitale
i vicini che se avesse divertire i
cinque seggi
allora questo fantastico ultimo colore
perché tale vediamo quali
vai ad esse di questo addormentava
niente allora ho toccato questo che
celeste chiaro ora ai colori forme carlo
salvia con la scelta si è sforato lista
ristretta andando cercando il gatto
perché sta minando la materia ho cercato
il gatto in opere seggi di roma
memoria penso che io sono stata più
fortunata di vitali chiederli la roma e
giallo
io invece un verde scuro un violetto e
un celestino
ma chi sia possibile a quelle originali
siamo pronti di gesù 09 sta andando
molto bene devo dire anche per me ecco
qua il mio allora in realtà il colore
rosa che avevano molto simile al viola
quindi sembrano quasi gli stessi colori
e di studi farla tutta gialla come
questo
e poi capelli viola questo rosa gli
occhi nostre le scarpette viola e rosa
quindi questa è la mia vediamo ora
quella di vitale a un minimo in verde
sempre minori che sono sceglie però io
mi sono fatto prendere dall'ispirazione
di questa piccola
ma questa gente la scarpa se unite con
la stampa e successo che ho confuso i
colori per farli dimostra un elemento
che dice al lago di no questo è il tuo
turno nella codina che 3com sulla testa
c'è lo chignon sulla testa che il signor
di orecchiette che sono più comodi e per
scoprirsi tucson ai morti ma che non si
vede niente se non è più lontano da
lontano
allora votate chi vince questo primo
turno con il sondaggio dove lo vinco io
ho vitale
ma per prugnoli e hamas che portiamo
razze con un disegno 3 2 1 abbiamo qua e
di dei pokémon che so perche i raggi x
carino mano è stata una cosa sbagliata
voi vi manca un dettaglio ma nella coda
perché mi ricordo che aveva la puntina
della coda bianca facciamo sapere nei
commenti se sono io che mi sto
sbagliando o se davvero gli mancano
questo tema io ricordo questa cosa è
vero sono super che dovrebbe vedere come
sia ivi tutto colorato quindi chi amiamo
il nostro assistente quando avrà visto
di fischiano tutta camarlinghi vitale
vediamo cosa sceglie al 7 il rosa forse
quando colore mischiamo lo so che ti
puoi mangiare tutto che cosa è se gli
incroci fortunato perché è davvero
marrone
il violetto detto fortunato
vediamo ora permetta di scegliere il
colore è questo è un arancione giallo
forse ci sta bene come tante fuori
secondo colore non il verde berlino non
il verde scusata marino ultima bravo ti
ha aiutato berlino però non dovrebbe
scegliere bene veramente come uscirai di
tutto verde marini lungo file di tipo
erba si anche sai ma che poi non di tipo
erba in vediamo se ci riesco vediamo io
invece come la troverò con questi colori
questa natura sono contento di come sta
uscendo non pensavo che sarebbe uscito
decente comunque di verdi non si sente
molto carino e di mezzi io sono un con
dietro allora marchi si vada ecco qua il
mio rivi di tipo erba devo dire che alla
fine se un sacco perché questo colore
marroncino che ha scelto berlino si sa
su per bene e sembra proprio di tipo
erba come ho fatto tipo la forma di una
foglia così sembra ancora più di tipo
erba quindi vi piace questo i video di
amore a quella di vita
che bello
non ci si è dimenticata di colorare che
hanno sottoposto a bianco le cose più
nette per chi per farlo ne farà meglio
il pianto perché hai fatto il rossetto e
che vuole c'è da è carina paesaggio è
tutto chiarito
vediamo l'originale non è cambiato molto
il rossetto è la chiosa cabala che ho
sfogliato fatto di rosa di chi è questo
ivi questo i b e pop si convince il mio
dio quella di vitali di tipo erba o
ibico del rossetto bordate terzo disegno
sono sempre gli animali quindi vede un
po 32 abbiamo dentro
beh ma questo è un gattino berlino non
piacerà tanto perché i primi due erano
dei cagnolini gli piacerebbe molto
negative dallo stato di piazzare altri
geloso del gatto questa purtroppo non
solo non ce l'ho real e quindi non me la
posso far vedere ma sono proprio per
note di vedere come il sì da noi la
savana sogno per me prima di berlino e
se gli permette si nota anche come prima
risposta e poi crescenti altro ne ha
presi due però ha preso questo adesso di
scegliere per me tale precetto ogni
scelta uno sbadiglio con allora maria si
sa che per me è sotto il guard la scelta
il giallo crea l'ultimo l'ultima 1
fucsia rosa
fortunato no grazie
lino grazie presidente per pensarlo e
lilla militare sbadiglia france grazie
assistette prendere allora non subisce
interruzioni segno che siamo ok
partiamo dettagli facciamo questo con la
mia non per allora ha deciso di farla
tutta di questo colore marroncino con
gli occhi verdi che sembrano quasi un
giallo poi capelli blu scuro viti super
bene e le perfette blu scuro e verdolino
e lo stesso
cosa ne pensate vediamo ora per la di
vitale che carina devo dire che questa
mentalità e ci sono stato più bravo di
tutti i dettagli gialli l'ascoli vicino
giallo e poi le cuffie verdi e rosa
i capelli rosa con il lucchetto tanto
carino
devo dire che questa è quella che ti
uscita meglio in italia sarebbero su
questa vincita quali il sondaggio chi
vince per il terzo round se vinco io ho
invece evitare
ora vi facciamo rivedere tutti e tre i
disegni credi serie the il vostro
preferito mio e il vostro preferito da
stili di vita allora votate il vostro
preferito tra i miei tre a me quello che
piace di più e ivi di tipo era anche a
messi all'inizio che ti è uscito bene io
invece fra i suoi di questa donna
anche perché la prima alla prima
mondiale è un alieno ma dimmi un po
particolare con quegli occhioni strani
ed è più bella è sicuramente questa
diffamati non è stato un bel mi piace
per fare altre challenger anche altre
sale in zucca berlino subito dopo questo
video andate a vedere la sigla della
serie la carmelina per vederla rilascio
al 33 candeline il cane su quella che
preferite e buona visione
ciao
[Musica]
nel cielo